Prof: So today we will
be talking about The German
Ideology,
and Marx becoming a historical
materialist.
I just wanted to make a couple
of more comments about "The
Theses on Feuerbach,"
where Marx is on the edge,
moving away from naturalism to
historical materialism.
But the emphasis in "The
Theses on Feuerbach"
is not so much on materialism,
but it is much more on praxis,
action,
change, the lack of
determination.
Marx, as a materialist,
is usually seen as a
determinist.
And if you took other courses
where much was--Marx was touched
upon, you were probably told
Marx is a determinist,
economic determinist.
And there's a lot of truth to
it, but half-truths,
and he is struggling in
"The Theses on
Feuerbach"--
as I said, he's on his way from
naturalism to materialism,
and the central idea is,
as I said,
praxis, human practices.
And that's why I put down on
the slides that it is a kind of
dialectical,
what Marx represents in
"The Theses on
Feuerbach".
Now Marx himself very rarely
used the term 'dialectical'.
He had a clear enough mind to
be suspicious about the word
'dialectics'.
Once, at an old age,
he wrote a letter to Engels and
he said, "You know
Friedrich what?
When I don't know what
something, then I say it is
dialectical."
Right?
And so dialectical means when
you couldn't really find out
what the relationship between
two phenomena is,
when you say,
"Well this is
dialectical."
Well it's a bit too simplistic.
The term 'dialectical',
as I am sure you all know,
go back to Greek philosophy.
But even in Greek philosophy,
the idea of dialectics was
emphasizing change and the
process.
A famous Greek philosopher once
said--and that tries to capture
the essence of
dialectics--"You cannot
step in the same river twice.
Because if you step in the
river, five minutes later it is
not quite the same river because
the water is gone;
this is a different
water." Right?
So that dialectics means that
the world is in flux,
is in change.
That's, I think,
one important idea of
dialectics.
And in "The Theses on
Feuerbach",
Marx emphasizes--right?--that
we are changing the world,
rather just taking it.
Right?
In this sense he's dialectical,
and this is why he still
resists materialism and
determinism.
There is another,
more contemporary adaptation of
the word dialectics,
which comes from Georg Hegel.
And Marx again was shying away
to use it very often.
But his friend Friedrich Engels
used it.
He even said there is a
dialectical materialism.
Engels made a distinction
between historical and
dialectical materialism.
Now what was dialectics in
Hegel?
Hegel was trying to capturing
the process of change.
Right?
Already in Greek philosophy the
dialecticians emphasized that if
you are looking at the world,
this is not a picture,
it is a movie--
right?--and every minute you
see something different.
Now Hegel tried to come to
terms with what is the essence
of this change?
In this essence of this change,
he was looking at
contradictions.
Contradictions drive the change.
So Hegel made a big distinction
between thesis,
antithesis and synthesis.
So the change,
what dialectics captures
normally in social life,
it starts with a thesis,
and actual conditions,
an antithesis,
which is the negation of the
situation,
and then it leads to a
synthesis, which is the negation
of the negation.
Right?
In some ways the original
condition is reconstituted,
but in a different way;
as Hegel put it,
"preserving it by
abolishing it."
Right?
That's the Hegelian insight
what actually was--this kind of
logic was attractive to Marx and
the Marxists.
Anyway, so this is dialectical.
And Marx, from dialectical,
from the philosophy of praxis
where praxis is crucial,
eventually moves towards a more
clearly deterministic,
positivistic social science in
which you have a very clearer
idea what is the key cause and
the consequences.
Right?
Doing very much what positivist
social science is doing today;
identifying the dependent
variable and independent
variable,
to come up with a hypothesis
how the dependent variable will
cause variation,
and the independent variable
will cause variation in the
dependent variable,
and then to describe it.
That is very much the mature
Marx.
And because Marx was moving
into, today we will call it
normal science,
he becomes a real scientist.
He was becoming so much of a
scientist that at one point he
began to doubt there is much
sense to make a distinction
between social sciences and
sciences.
He himself began to see himself
as the Darwin of social
sciences.
He was so much attracted with
scientific reasoning--
the late Marx,
the second Marx we will start
talking about--
that he actually for awhile
considered to dedicate the book,
Kapital,
to Charles Darwin,
because he saw himself as doing
for human history what Marx did
to the evolution of the species.
He wanted to do an evolution of
human societies.
Now luckily for Marx he did not
do that.
Right?
He did not become a social
Darwinist.
Right?
He resisted the temptation.
But he was tempted.
Okay, I just want to go back
very briefly to two "Theses
on Feuerbach,"
because they are very
important.
Right?
And this is the idea. Right?
He is now
criticizing--right?--Feuerbach.
And the problem with Feuerbach,
he said,
that Feuerbach,
and other people who were
materialists before him,
they thought that there are
things outside there,
objective things,
which are outside of the
subject,
which creates a knowledge about
these objects--
he called that
Gegenstand,
object--
and the knowledge is nothing
else but a reflection in human
mind of the object outside
there.
This is a very typical theory
of truth.
Right?
Very widely shared today,
and probably a theory of truth
what many of you in this room
share.
Right?
When is your knowledge accurate?
You think about your mind as a
mirror.
If the image of the object,
or the objective world outside,
is accurately reflected in the
mirror of your mind,
then you got it.
Right?
So what we try to do is to have
the most perfect mirror in our
mind,
and capture the objective
reality as precisely and as much
in detail as possible.
Well Marx says this is simply,
you know, reflection,
and we should go beyond that.
Right?
He said, "What is good
about what Feuerbach did,
what is good what"--for
instance, what Montesquieu did.
These were the two people we
discussed so far who were
clearly, you know,
materialist;
though I mean Hobbes was pretty
much a materialist as well,
believing that this is sort of
biological conditions which
drive us and makes us what we
are.
So they all started from
sensuousness.
Right?
That the reality is something
what we can get at through our
senses.
Right?
We smell it,
we touch it,
we see it, and unless we touch
it, we see it,
we smell it,
we doubt whether it exists.
Right?
That's the
difference--right?--between
materialist and idealist.
Ideas you don't get through
your senses.
Right?
You get it through your mind.
But he said this is--this
materialism is sensuous only in
the sense of contemplation.
The object is outside of the
subject and you get a grasp of
it through your senses.
And he said,
"Well, but what I am
suggesting in my new approach is
sensuous--
all right?--but a sensuous
human activity--
an activity, as such."
I mentioned very briefly that
this, in the last lecture--let
me just make--come back to this
point again.
This is what Jürgen
Habermas, arguably the greatest
philosopher of the twentieth
century--well he's still alive
but he may--you know?
The twenty-first century has a
long way to go to decide who
will be the greatest
philosopher.
But many thinks that
Jürgen Habermas was the
greatest philosopher of the
twentieth century.
He said, "Well yes,
Marx in "The Theses on
Feuerbach"
is right"
at one point.
I mean, Habermas had his
'culture' turn,
moved away from materialism.
But in most of his life he
said, "I am a materialist
because I also believe that the
ultimate reality has to come
through sensuous experiences,
through the senses." Right?
But he said,
"Marx later on,
the mature Marx became
reductionist,
because the sensuous activity
he identified with the economy,
with production,
with economic activities."
And he said,
"In "The Theses on
Feuerbach"
he got it right.
All sensuous activity are
material."
"So therefore,"
he says,
"let's not simply limit
our analysis to production,
but let's look at human
interaction."
When we interact with each
other, this is also a sensuous
activity.
Right?
So he creates peace between
Sigmund Freud and Karl Marx.
Many people try to do that.
Right?
That this is not an opposition,
that it is either production or
your sexual drives.
You know, your sexual
drives--your sexual interaction
with others--is very much
sensuous.
Right?
It's actually more sensuous
than doing a job--right?-- than,
you know, being in McDonald's
and serving hamburgers.
That's sensuous activity.
But all right,
you know, sexual interaction is
very much sensuous.
That's Habermas's point.
And Marx, in "The Theses
on Feuerbach",
opens this possibility up.
It's a very open argument.
Okay?
This is actually one of the
reasons why he does not publish
it.
It's too vague.
He wanted to be more precise,
and then he wanted to go--
he was reading Adam Smith and
Ricardo,
and spent all of his time in
the British Library reading
these economists,
and he wanted to bring it back
down to earth,
to the economy and economic
interest.
And now let me start to this,
because I think that's very
important the theory of truth.
And I want you to think about
it.
I think this is very
interesting.
So what is truth?
And to be very
simplistic--right?--you have two
competing theories of truth.
One theory of truth,
what I think most of you have
in your mind,
is the kind of reflection
theory of truth--that our mind
is a mirror.
More accurately it reflects the
objective reality out there more
true, the knowledge what we have
in our mind is.
And Marx, in "The Theses
on Feuerbach",
says, "Not so.
The truth is a practical
question.
The problem with the reflection
theory of truth is that it is
positivist and it is
alienated."
I'll throw in another word
coined by a major Marxist
philosopher of the twentieth
century, Georg Lukács.
He called it this is reified
consciousness.
Reified--you know,
Lukács was writing in
German, and in German he used
the term Verdinglichung.
Ding means a thing.
I think reification is a very
good translation.
Only those of us who speak
English but do not speak Latin
don't necessarily quite get it.
Right?
Rei in Latin means the
thing.
Reification is the process in
which we turn stuff,
what is not a thing,
into an objective thing.
It's a kind
of--right?--Lukácsian
reinterpretation of Marx's
notion of alienation.
Marx's term,
in German, for reification was
Entfremdung;
fremd means alien. Right?
So alienation is a good
translation.
Right?
You are alienated if you feel
alien, if you feel homeless in
this world.
Now I think but Lukács
has an interesting idea--
right?--that the essence of
alienation is when we're
beginning to see the world,
what actually we created--the
world is our creation and this
objective world will rule us.
We do not see ourselves as the
masters of the world,
but we see ourselves as ruled
by the world.
Right?
And this is reified
consciousness,
when we're beginning to see the
objective reality,
we cannot do anything about it.
Right?
And the essence is the
philosophy of praxis of the
young Marx,
ending--right?--with "The
Theses on Feuerbach",
the point is to change it;
the point is to change the
world.
So in contemporary discourse we
usually call this positivism.
Right?
Positivists are those social
scientists who think there are
objective facts out there,
and the purpose of social
investigation is to establish
most objectively and most
concretely what those objective
social facts are.
You are an economist,
you describe the objective
facts.
Right?
You say, "Well you have to
maximize profit,
because if you do not maximize
profit,
then you will be wiped out of
business."
Right?
This is almost like a force of
nature.
Again, if I can recall Georg
Lukács,
he coined this wonderful term
second nature.
Right?
That we're beginning to think
about social life as if it were
natural, as if it would have the
power of nature;
the economic laws look like
lightening.
You know?
Like, you know,
this force-- like earthquakes.
Right?
You can't do virtually nothing
about an earthquake.
If we can't predict what we
can't predict,
we can just get into our car
and get out of it.
Right?
But even we cannot really
predict earthquakes.
That's one of the problems.
Right?
Well now we can predict when a
hurricane is coming.
What can we do?
You get in the car and get out
of there, where the hurricane
will come.
Now, you know,
the point is that positivism
does posits social phenomena as
if they had the force of nature.
And that's what Lukács
called we create the social
world as if it were second
nature, as if it had the force
of nature.
He said this is all wrong
because this is the world what
we created.
We should rule it. Right?
That's the idea,
to overcome alienation;
to become the master of your
fate.
Right?
To be able--right?--to change
the objective conditions.
And we will--you know,
in The German Ideology,
Marx puts it very powerfully.
I would say it's almost the
last word what in this debate he
said-- was said.
I don't think anybody really
improved on it.
He said, "Well,
humans change the conditions.
But we were born under certain
conditions, and we can only
change the conditions we were
born into."
Right?
So it's an interesting
interaction between yes,
I mean we can't do
anything--right?--
because we were born into
conditions,
but within some limits we can
change those conditions.
By the way, it's not all that
different from
Hobbes--right?--and voluntary
action, the theory of voluntary
action.
There is a similarity here.
Now I'll finish this and get
onto The German Ideology.
But there is one thing what I
cannot leave out,
too--I think too insightful and
important to leave it out.
So let me come back to this
subject and object issue.
Right?
What I've suggested,
it is so extremely important,
not only for Marx but for the
whole critical theory,
and, in fact,
for anti-positivism of all
sorts in the twentieth and
twenty-first century.
I mentioned,
for instance,
cultural theory,
which is very strongly
anti-positivist--right?--and
rejects social science as normal
science.
So what we have is subject.
And that is you--right?--the
person who has a consciousness
and is a cognitive subject--is
involved in cognitive activity,
creating knowledge.
And then there are objects
about which we create knowledge.
Reflection theory of truth said
that this is a mirror and if the
objects are accurately described
in the mirror of our mind,
that is truth.
This is the whole test of
having verification of
hypotheses.
Right?
I develop a hypothesis.
Then I go there and test it on
the social reality,
and if it is matches,
then it is verified,
I got truth.
Right?
Now the philosophy of praxis
says that truth is not simply a
reflection, it's an interaction
between subject and object;
that's where truth is.
And there is this wonderful
philosopher-- not a very easy
read, but still I think a
wonderful mind.
His name is Adorno.
Adorno belonged to the
Frankfurt School and was active
mainly in the 1940s and
'60s--'30s and '60s.
And well he formulated this so
powerfully.
He said, "What is
truth?"
He said, "The truth is the
force-field between subject and
object."
Right?
"Not simply a reflection
of the object,
but it is between the tension
of subject and object."
Right?
I think this is beautifully
done.
Right?
It is in the force-field of
subject and object.
So let me also add one more
point, and then we can move away
the theory of truth.
But I want you guys to think
about what is truth?
Right?
When can you say an idea is
true?
In fact, Adorno at one point
said about Nazism.
You know?
He said--experiencing,
he was Jewish and many of his
family were killed--right?--by
the Nazis.
And he said,
"The reality,
Nazi reality,
is so miserable that it does
not deserve to be called
true."
You see the point?
You also say that occasionally,
when you see something horrible
and you can say,
"No, that cannot be
true." Right?
This is exactly Adorno's point.
This can be so miserable that
you say it cannot be true.
And the idea is that they are
so miserable that you are
completely powerlessness about
these nature-like forces though
it is unacceptable--right?
You should be able to do
something about it.
Right?
We should have been able to do
something about Auschwitz,
and they could not do anything
about it.
And that's what Adorno said.
This reality was such that it
should not be called true;
it cannot be truth.
You see what it is getting at?
A very final point about this
theory of truth,
and this is through another
guy, Karl Mannheim.
This is very much along this
line.
He was very much not a Marxist.
He was a conservative
philosopher.
His major work was done in
England.
Mannheim once said,
"The truth is not being.
The truth is becoming."
Bingo. Right?
Wonderfully put. Right?
The truth is not simply that
you describe how things are.
You really know what the truth
is when you know what it can be,
and what you can do
about it.
The real purpose of cognition
is not simply to describe the
world but to change
it--right?--to make it a better
world.
That's when you have real
truth, when you know how to make
the world better.
Right?
So the truth is not being but
becoming.
And that's the philosophy of
praxis.
But I think that's where Marx
is in writing "The Theses
on Feuerbach",
and that's what he is moving
away from when he's beginning to
write The German
Ideology.
But he is writing together with
Friedrich Engels.
And now you see he has to
abandon--he cannot publish the
book-- "The Theses on
Feuerbach"
because it is too
voluntaristic.
Right?
He abandoned The Paris
Manuscript because it was
fluffy.
Right?
"Nobody will believe me
that the revolution will come
because the proletariat is
alienated."
And then when he finished--I
think this--I mean,
not all eleven sentences are
great, but some of those
sentences are really great
sentences.
He wrote it down and he never
published it because he said,
"Well, this is too
voluntaristic."
Right?
"I have to come up with a
more- with a theory which will
prove to people that the
revolution will come.
Capitalism has to fall.
It is not only a question
whether we decide to change it
or we don't have to change
it." Right?
"I have to come up with a
theory which will prove that
capitalism will have to
fall." Right?
That's what puts him into the
deterministic mode.
He actually becomes never
really deterministic.
It's a very simplistic reading
of Marx.
You know, after all this guy is
a theorist of the revolution.
He thought that revolutionary
ideas should be put into
people's head.
This idea did not think that
ideas do not matter.
If he would have believed ideas
do not matter,
he would not have spent,
you know, all of his time,
eight in the morning,
nine-- until nine p.m.
in the British library,
and writing books.
Right?
If ideas do not matter,
why do you write down ideas?
Because he believed that ideas
will change the world.
Right?
So he was never completely a
deterministic.
But in the nature of the work
he's moving towards economic
determinism.
And the reason is that now he
wants to prove that
capitalism--yes,
it had great achievement.
During the time of capitalism
society developed more than ever
before capitalism.
But nevertheless it will have
to come an end.
Capitalism will not last
forever.
And now he has to prove that
thesis, that it must come to an
end.
So that puts him on a
deterministic trajectory.
That's what makes him--he has
to become--he has to accept
materialism;
that material conditions
determine human action and
consciousness.
So that's what he--they are
beginning to develop in The
German Ideology.
And this is the structure of
the book.
The first chapter is a critique
on Feuerbach;
takes on from "The Theses
on Feuerbach"
but tightens the argument and
becomes strictly materialist,
and gets out of this
voluntaristic element.
He has some introductory
remarks about critique of
idealism and the premises of the
new materialism he is proposing
now,
what he's beginning to call now
historical materialism--
stays away from the word
'dialectical'.
And then he develops--right?--a
materialist conception of
history and historical
development.
He replaces Adam Smith's
categorization of societies as
hunting, gathering,
grazing, agricultural or
commercial with a new typology.
This new typology will be the
typology of the modes of
production.
Not--in fact,
in The German Ideology
he stays pretty close to Adam
Smith.
I will point this out.
And this is one of his problems.
This is one of the reasons why
The German Ideology was
also left unfinished and
unpublished.
Right?
As I indicated,
it was first published--and not
the complete text--only in 1903,
well after the deaths of Marx
and Engels.
Then he writes about the
origins of idealist conception
of history, where it is coming
from.
He's writing about the
development of productive
forces, and eventually this
covers the notion of relations
of production.
I will make a big deal out of
this,
because I think that's one of
the reasons that The German
Ideology fails,
that until the very end he does
not know the term of relations
of production,
and he runs into some very big
problems.
And then he writes on Bruno
Bauer and Max Stirner.
These are Young Hegelians.
People usually don't read these
chapters.
And Volume II,
I mean you must be a Marx
expert to read this.
This is really basically
irrelevant, not very
interesting.
Okay, what are the major themes
in The German Ideology?
First, he offers a materialist
view of history.
Then he offers a theory of
modes of production.
Then he's beginning to develop
forces of production and
initially division of labor;
and this is a problem.
This is very much Adam Smith.
He's still very strongly under
Adam Smith and understands the
evolution of society as the
evolution of division of labor.
And then he describes-- tries
to describe the forces of
production and division of
labor--
modes of production and
describes a subsection and modes
of production and give a very
about human history.
And then he develops what I
would call--
he's the first who creates a
sociology of knowledge--
how to study sociologically,
socially how you can understand
conscience,
human consciousness.
Okay, so the materialist view
of history.
And now here you can see Marx
the positivist social scientist
speaking.
And Marx is the first of
positivist social
scientists--rigorous positivist
scientist.
And what he describes here will
be subscribed and accepted most
of the positivist types in your
political science or sociology
or economics or psychology
departments.
Right?
He said, "The premises
from which we begin with are not
arbitrary ones;
not dogmas but real premises,
from which abstractions can
only be made in the
imagination."
So you start from the objective
conditions and then you
speculate from this.
So what we start are real
individuals, and the activities
of these individual;
actual activities of these
individuals.
And then he moves a little
further.
Their conditions of life,
both what they find already
existing and those what they
produce by their activities.
Right?
So, he said,
"German philosophers
descended from the heaven to
earth.
Now we are ascending from earth
to heaven."
Right?
"We do not deduction,
we do induction.
This is the inductive method
what we use."
And if you are a positivist,
you will love it.
You see, this is real serious
science--right?--looking at
facts.
And then he said,
"Well ideas have no
history, no development.
Man developing the material
conditions, and then material
intercourse, altered their
thinking.
So it is really our material
existence which has a history,
and ideas reflect those
material conditions."
And then he's beginning to
develop the theory of modes of
production.
He said, "Well,
man can distinguish from
animals in different ways.
But most important is that we
produce, that we change the
environment in a purposeful
manner.
Right?
That we have an image how to
change the physical environment
for us.
"And what actually matters
is not simply what we produce--
and this is a very important
idea--"but the mode of
production,
how we produce,
how we engage each other.
Because this will change in
history,not simply what we
produce."
Well this is a revolutionary
idea.
Again, this is completely new
in Marx.
Before Marx,
you went into a museum and the
museum was about great people.
Right?
These were kings and queens and
generals and popes whose
pictures were presented there,
and this was the way how
history was described.
Now you go into a history,
and now you can see this is a
living room,
how people lived in Roman
times, and this is the way how
they ate,
this is the way how they
cooked, and these are the
instruments by which they
produced the stuff what they
cooked in their kitchen.
Right?
This is how a modern historical
museum looks like,
and this comes--this is really
a revolution from Marx.
History is not the history of
great ideas and great men,
or great women.
History is the idea of the
actual way how people lived and
produced and reproduced their
ideas.
Well he said, "Well,
we can distinguish therefore
differences between nature,
how the productive
forces"--
he means by
technology--"is developing
and how"--
he uses initially the term the
inter--
"the intercourse,
internal intercourse is
changing."
And by this he refers to
division of labor.
A very Smithsian idea,
Adam Smith's idea.
Right?
That history evolves a greater
division of labor--
we will see in Emile Durkheim
also this central idea--
you can see the evolution of
society by increasing division
of labor.
And then he tries to come up
with subsequent modes of
production.
Now he said,
"Now I actually can
describe the history as
different types of mode of
production, moving from
elementary forms.
The most elementary form is
tribal society.
In tribal society where the
technology is very simple and
there is very little division of
labor"--
he is sexist enough to
say--"there is a natural
division of labor between men
and women.
Men go hunting and women go
collecting woods in the
forest."
And that he calls natural.
This is, of course,
a sexist proposition.
But, you know,
he was writing it in 1845--was
not the only man who was sexist.
"Well the second form
is," he said,
"ancient communal or state
property; antiquity."
Now you have development of
forces of production,
and in fact you have a
separation of ownership and
greater division of labor,
where now people can produce
more than necessary for their
survival.
Therefore there will be slaves
who will be working day and
night, and there will be
philosophers who sit in Athens
and Rome and have great ideas.
Right?
Because the slaves produce the
stuff, what they can eat and
they can enjoy.
So the division of labor
evolves.
And then the third,
now we have the evolution of
feudalism.
Well slaves were great,
producing cheap,
but the problems with slaves
were that they did not have much
incentive to use very
complicated technology.
You had to supervise them very
closely because they really
hated your guts and if they
could they did
break--right?--the instruments
if t.
So you did want to give them
complex technologies.
So you invent serfdom.
You say, "You know,
why don't you become a serf
rather than a slave?
You can have your house and
I'll give you a piece of land.
And if you behave yourself,
two days you work on my estate
and you produce stuff for me,
and I'll let you to spend the
rest of the week producing for
yourself."
But the big problem is that
with the evolution of feudalism,
the fall of Rome and Greece
and, you know,
rise of Charlemagne and,
you know, the Dark Middle Ages,
the division of labor did not
develop.
There was less division of
labor in the eleventh and
twelfth century than it was in
the first and second century.
So the methodology breaks down.
Marx is in deep trouble.
And as you can see,
you can read the text,
he leaves after this the page
blank.
He said, >
, "I'm in trouble."
Right?
"I have to start this all
over again."
And he starts all over again
and tries to come up with
something better.
Well sociology of knowledge,
a very important contribution.
This is unfortunately
completely wrong,
what he's saying,
but the methodology is
extremely important,
and informed people who were
studying cognition and knowledge
ever since.
And he makes this very
important suggestion.
"Well life determines
consciousness"
rather than the other way
around.
And the other argument,
which I think is desperately
wrong,
but very insightful:
"Ruling class always
determines the ruling ideas of
each people."
Now life determines
consciousness.
And this is kind of the
essence--right?--of materialism.
Right?
"Definite individuals,
who are productively active in
a definite way,
enter into definite social and
political relationships.
The production of ideas is at
first directly interwoven with
material activity and the
material intercourse of
man."
Tell me, you know,
how much money you have in your
pocket and I will tell you what
your ideas are,
to put it very simplistically.
Right?
Tell me which class you belong
to and I will be able to tell
you what your ideas are.
Right?
Well indeed,
you know, there is a strong
class component,
for instance,
in voting behavior;
not so much in the United
States, because in the United
States if you are poor,
you usually do not vote.
Right?
And therefore,
you know, the Democratic Party
is kind of scrambling to get a
little working class vote;
more than that,
without scaring the middle
class away for voting them.
Right?
That's the big traditional
trouble of the Democratic Party.
But if you look at Europe or
you look at Australia--the
Australian Labor Party was
getting a solid,
you know, working class vote.
So tell me what your class
position is and I will tell you
how you will vote in the next
elections.
As I said, in the U.S.
it doesn't work.
But it does work in Sweden.
It did work in England for a
long time.
It, by and large,
worked in Australia.
Right?
If you are--to some extent it
even works in the United States.
Well there are some very rich
people who are Democrats.
But typically those guys who
are very rich,
don't they tend to be
Republican?
Right?
I think they probably do. Right?
So, I mean, there is--this is
what Marxists are getting at.
Right?
"Tell me,
you know, what your materialist
interests are and then I'll tell
you what is on your mind."
Reductionist.
Again we will read Sigmund
Freud.
He said, "Well true."
But this is not only economic
interest.
"Tell me the history of
your sex life and I'll tell you
what is on your mind."
Right?
You know, it's an analogous
argument.
Right?
It is existence which
determines consciousness.
Right?
Both of them said,
"Well, it's not
necessarily true,
that what is in your mind true.
But I know where it is coming
from." Right?
"You were in love with
your mother--
right?--if you were a
man--"and you suppressed
all your desire for your mother,
and that's why you have
your--these false ideas in your
mind." Right?
"Or you were a--you are a
girl and you were loving father.
You could not fulfill this love.
Suppress your desire and you
have all these strange ideas
there.
That's why you are neurotic.
Right?
And I can tell you." Right?
That's the way how Marx will
argue it.
Sort of, you know--this is also
reductionist,
by the way.
But there is a common
interesting idea:
who we are biologically,
class-wise, race-wise,
gender-wise,
that makes a difference.
I see in the discussion
sections.
Very often--right?--if we have
a real hot topic--
you know, do you want to have
universal healthcare,
for instance,
well there is usually a gender
division in the class.
Right?
Sort of, you know,
gender has an impact.
Right?
Well speaking about it,
I get into affirmative action.
Right?
Well of course we are in a
liberal university.
Few people dare to speak up
against affirmative action.
But, you know,
among white males well there is
usually less
articulation--right?--to defend
the idea of affirmative action.
Woman and minorities are more
likely to defend it.
Okay?
So I know who you are,
I know what your ideas will be.
Right?
Your interests form your ideas.
That's the idea.
I think this is a very
important idea.
Right?
Put in a simplistic way.
And that comes to the idea that
the ruling class is really
producing the ruling ideas.
Well not quite true,
but there is an element of
truth to it.
Right?
There is an ideological
hegemony in the world.
Okay, that's about it for today.
Thank you.